Speaker 1: So I didn't cover this yesterday,
but more has happened than I do want to say
a little bit about it, a radical Republican
Congresswoman, Marjorie Taylor Green, a major
conspiracy theorist, a note of disinformation.
That's I know D.C., my friends.
I know.
I'll get emails about that one.
She was suspended from Twitter for 12 hours.
Now, you can interpret that as Twitter is
finally expanding its reach in terms of really
clamping down on the disinformation and misinformation.
Or you could see it as 12 hours is completely
meaningless.
It's symbolic.
And it merely provided Marjorie Taylor Green
with the opportunity to weaponize the ban
and continue perpetuating conspiracy theories,
including about social media vendettas against
her.
Which do you think it was?
Mostly the second.
I mean, 12 hours.
Let's look at what we know about it.
New York Times writing Twitter suspends Marjorie
Taylor Green for posting covid misinformation.
The Republican lawmaker from Georgia cannot
tweet for 12 hours after the White House criticized
social media sites for amplifying vaccine
lies.
Twitter said on Monday it was suspending green
for 12 hours after she posted messages that
violated its policy against sharing misleading
information about the coronavirus.
Green of Georgia has been an outspoken opponent
of vaccines and masks as tools to curb the
pandemic.
In tweets on Sunday and Monday, she argued
that covid-19 was not dangerous from for people
unless they were obese or over age 65 and
said vaccines should not be required.
Now, of course, they're not from the standpoint
of any kind of government mandate.
There are private businesses and institutions
which as an anti regulation Republican, she
certainly should respect their ability to
say here's who we want to do business with
or don't, or here are the requirements to
work here as long as they don't violate the
law.
The article goes on to say, With cases of
the virus on the rise and the highly contagious
Delta variant accounting for more than half
of new infections in the US, federal health
officials say this month.
And Miss Green's home state, Georgia, new
cases have increased.
One hundred and ninety three percent in the
past two weeks.
Twitter is said Green's tweets were misinformation
and barred her until Tuesday, quote, We took
enforcement action on the account empty Greaney
for violations of the Twitter rules, specifically
the covid-19 misleading information policy.
Miss Green said Silicon Valley companies are
working with the White House to attack speech,
free speech.
These big tech companies are doing the bidding
of the Biden regime to restrict our voices
and prevent the spread of a message that's
not state approved.
Twitter took action after Biden called on
social media companies to do more to combat
the spread of vaccine misinformation on their
platform.
Biden said sites like Facebook are killing
people.
So, you know, the problem here is, of course,
Marjorie Taylor Greene is spreading dangerous
covid and vaccine disinformation on Twitter.
There's no doubt whatsoever.
There's no doubt it violates Twitter's terms
of service.
The issue I have is what are we really doing
by doing this for 12 hours?
Now, if it's this is the first time, it's
12 hours, and next time it'll be a week, and
next time it'll be a full suspension.
OK, I could be convinced that taking a lighter
touch now maybe makes some sense, but the
problem is that this is all a closed loop.
They claim that social media censoring them,
they then post vaccine conspiracies that are
dangerous, this disinformation.
So they get banned and then they say, see,
I told you so.
I told you that they're censoring us.
I told you that they're banning us.
It's duck sarcastic closure.
That's a term I used before.
It's a logical closure.
Another way to say it is that these are self-fulfilling
beliefs.
It's a win win in some sense for Marjorie
Taylor Green.
Either she gets to keep peddling disinformation
on Twitter or she gets banned and then says,
I'm a martyr.
They've canceled me, I'm the most canceled
woman or whatever the case.
So it ends up kind of being a gift.
I think it's better to ban her in a serious
way if she's going to be spreading the disinformation,
which she is, which violates Twitter policy.
And as soon as she got back on Twitter because
it was only a 12 hour ban, she first likened
the suspension to communist China, tweeting,
American social media company Twitter banned
me for 12 hours, censoring me, violating my
freedom of speech.
That's, of course, not true.
Twitter's a private company.
They can enforce terms of service.
She said, you know who else silences censors
and bans people they don't like and want heard?
Communist China.
Communism is not good.
Save America, stop communism.
You know who else breathes oxygen?
Hitler, right?
I mean, that's essentially what this is then
tweeting Foushee lied, people died, fire foushee
then tweeting a picture of herself doing a
press conference, which we'll talk about momentarily.
So captioning it.
Communist style Twitter ban press conference
happening now and then tweeting Sports Illustrated
featured a trans biological male and an elite
female tennis player this year, just Sports
Illustrated see the irony in promoting a trans
and a female athlete when biological men are
now being allowed to defeat women in women's
sports, promoting men defeating women is WOAK
so immediately going into more antiscience
stuff.
The fire foushee attack FOUSHEE thing is a
big anti science movement.
Now, we're going to talk more about that tomorrow.
We talked about it earlier today doing anti
trans stuff.
She immediately should be banned again if
Twitter actually wants us to believe that
she's taking this seriously.
Next, I want to talk about this press conference
that she held, which is just completely out
of this world.